across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare i'm preparing my
family for the total destruction of the
power graders the yellowstone super
volcano a financial collapse and protect
themselves when survival is the goal
it's into the spider hole
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
what i'm gonna use
next we go inside the lives of three
committed preppers who have devised
extensive plans i have just over 11 000
types of seeds on this floor gone to
great lengths
you're crazy brave and made huge
personal sacrifices to ensure their very
survival shoot your thumb off oh this is
a bomb
this this could be a
bomb burn them down the experts will
assess their extreme preps and decide if
they have what it takes to face
armageddon honey i'm home play this this
is great
and to survive
this is doomsday preppers
[Music]
mike mester is a contractor living in a
suburb near atlanta georgia he has a
loving wife
a brood of kids
two dogs and a spacious home in a quiet
development
and
we're preparing for civil unrest caused
by a global economic collapse
prepping it's just become a way of life
for for me and my family y2k certainly
had an impact on myself and then the
game changer for me was 9 11.
all of our children understand why we
prep
they see what's going on in the world
they see what's going on in their
country
there's a storm brewing out there it's
brewing all over the place
the way the united states economy works
today is not sustainable
we were once the greatest creditor in
the world now we are the greatest debtor
where will the money come from
look at the news look in the papers
police departments cut
fire departments cut
what will you do when there's no one
there
mike believes that as the global economy
falters the u.s will fall deeper and
deeper into debt
banks will close
power will go out
basic services will grind to a halt if
the grocery shelves are empty
you're only nine meals away from anarchy
what will happen then
will you be prepared
we have a saying five minutes before the
prom is not the time to learn how to
dance
mike and his wife lisa have been
prepping for over a decade they devote
at least an hour a day to making their
suburban home a family fortress we do
key preps throughout the house we keep
in the storage area in our garage
closets in our basement but as his
children grow older mike is facing new
challenges
while most preppers agree that staying
together is key to family survival
mike's oldest son ryan now lives at
college around 250 miles away
mike conducts regular video conferences
with ryan so how's college going not to
talk about grades or tuition but to
discuss their family plan to survive the
end of the world as we know it
you guys are trying to keep your gas
tanks at least half full at all times oh
yeah i always make sure my truck is that
fall you've been watching the news
what's going on over in greece and
everything else and down on the border
and yeah hey mom wants to say hi to you
hey ryan how are you to my wife and i
our home is our family
that's why we want to ensure that we get
all our children home when things
collapse
we will go to any extent to ensure their
safety
we've provided them with a get home bag
aluminum foil
duct tape
consists of water food things to help
you protect you from the element sources
of light in a lantern with extra
batteries
there's enough here to support them for
four days with about 1500 calories with
everything that's here
heaven forbid
our oldest boy can't make it home that's
why we have plans to retrieve him in 30
days
mike believes that after an economic
collapse rioting will spread from urban
centers in waves with violence cresting
in the first few weeks so 30 days is a
key time frame for braving the road that
retrieval of our sun will involve a
minimum of two of us to take our gas
stores and travel down to college and
we'll find him there in his dorm room
all right take care love you too
mike fears that an economic collapse
will cause a run on gasoline making it
difficult for him to quickly fuel his
car and retrieve ryan so we got 45
gallons we just need to go uh fill that
last one up there and we'll have our 50
gallon stores on hand
the 50 gallons mike keeps in his garage
is enough to take him over 800 miles or
three times the distance to his son's
campus
gasoline has a shelf life between nine
months to two years so mike goes to the
gas station and replenishes his
stockpiles every three months just to be
on the safe side a little bit of time
today rotating our gas stores out
but what happens when fuel's not
available uh just having that extra fuel
on hand could become uh a lifesaver if
you got to go get somebody that's out
there you know we're just gonna transfer
the fuel out of this five gallon fill up
the other one over there
all right we're almost there we'll swap
it over he is also teaching his son kyle
methods for stealing gasoline if
necessary
this will work in some older model cars
a lot of vehicles that are out there
have any siphoning devices you can't get
it down there
or if it comes down to it they have two
and a half gallon gas cans they use that
and just the regular punch all put the
can underneath the car punch a hole in
it and just let it drain in
pretty much if you're gonna get out of
dodge you're gonna do what you need to
get out of dodge
mike isn't just prepping for his wife
and kids
there are two other members of the
family that he's also looking out for
if things get bad
we do have preparations for our dogs as
well
he's even equipped them with bug-out
bags
a lot of people don't think about their
pets
we have over a quarter ton of dog food
for our two german shepherds well i
guess he doesn't want to bug out and
shelter in place so
real boy
it's amazing our own government tells us
about having at least a three-day supply
of food and water on hand
as a prepper it's gone a little bit
further than that chew chopped onions
my prior careers is being a logistician
and understanding warehousing gives us
an advantage on how we manage our stores
seven cases of refried beans
right now our estimates are we have two
years
of food for 10 people
having one well-stocked pantry is sander
for a prepper but mike has dedicated
three rooms of his 4 500 square foot
house to food storage
mike stores thousands of cans sometimes
for years past their expiration date
expired food may not taste good but mike
knows it could keep his family alive in
a crisis there's a difference between
shelf life and life sustaining in third
world countries they use rancid cooking
oil certainly it will not hurt you
believe it or not this is meatloaf
canned meats like beef chicken bacon
sausage it's not pretty looking but it's
actually quite tasty
for the mesters the looming threat of an
economic collapse touches every aspect
of suburban life every autumn while the
other neighborhood kids rake and dispose
of dead leaves mike has his kids gather
and save them they'll use them as a prep
to survive a winter without fuel or
electricity
one of the fuel sources that there's an
abundance of in suburbia is newspaper
we're basically going to take this and
we're going to take some natural
materials this is just some dried leaves
we're gonna mix this together
and we're gonna soak it for about five
days
let's start filling up the mold first
mike has challenged his kids to make six
thousand of these briquettes enough fuel
to keep them warm for three to four
winter months
so once we compress it we have kind of
like uh you know those logs you buy at
the grocery store
many third world countries use this as
an alternative heat and cooking source
after pressing the water out of the
slurry and a week of air drying the
briquettes are ready to go
colleen how's that looking
okay
the living room fireplace is a gathering
spot in many homes but few families in
georgia huddle around an arctic stove
like mike's which can burn even at
sub-zero temperatures
one briquette
will get about a 25 to 30 minute burn
time
stocking the mester compound with a
year's worth of food is a start but to
survive an economic collapse mike
believes his family will need to learn
how to defend themselves so he is
getting the whole family combat ready
before the suburban streets are overrun
with chaos
suburban dad mike mester believes global
economic collapse will ignite civil
unrest across america he stockpiled
mountains of food and taught his
children how to harvest fuel from the
backyard
now he must teach them to defend their
preps by whatever means necessary
security is important part of the
prepper's lifestyle if there's an
economic collapse
civil unrest will most likely ensue the
metropolitan areas then spread out to
the suburbs
downtown atlanta is only 45 miles away
we don't know how fast that civil unrest
will get to us but we certainly will be
prepared if it does
[Music]
we have weapons for every individual in
a house
12 gauge shotguns
high high-powered rifles
civilian versions of military firearms
sidearms and plenty of ammunition for
all of them uh give me those and just
take them out that's headed range
once a month mike and his kids load the
family arsenal into the suv and head off
for practice
shooting ranges located in residential
suburbs are popular destinations for
prepper families in part because they
offer the opportunity to fire at human
shape targets
if you don't practice you can easily
lose that skill set the average attacker
can cover 21 feet in 1.5 seconds so
preppers looking to defend themselves
must evaluate a threat and terminate it
within a fraction of a second if there
was a threat in the house and and i
wasn't available i would expect them to
do whatever they needed to defend
themselves and hopefully the dogs would
do it first
two german shepherds storm and thunder
they're part of our family and they're
also part of our security the final part
of mike's security preparations is
turning the family's two house bats into
defensive weapons
these two german shepherds may look
friendly but each one possesses a
natural fight drive
proper training works to pull the
maximum attack instinct out of each dog
we want to get them a little more
aggressive should the time come for the
need
what in particular you're looking at for
training for your dog well one of the
things that i'd like to see if they're
capable of is providing a little bit
more security it's the training that
makes the difference that makes or
breaks the dog
it actually makes or breaks a
relationship with the family as well
come on come
the first step to making the master pets
combat ready is running them through a
series of agility tests and obstacles
challenges beyond the usual walk around
the cul-de-sac
[Music]
this obstacle course trains the master
children to give commands in a uniform
way consistency among family members is
a critical element of protection dog
training male he's pretty big he can
knock me over but if he comes up to you
and knocks you over he'll roll over and
want you to scratch his belly
today mike is getting a look at a highly
trained attack dog something he and his
family hope storm and thunder will
become
dogs bite pretty hard it's not something
you want to take
without anything on
so in real life
you can lose something
[Music]
look at that
house
just stops on her command
you can call back a dog you can't call
back a bullet i got it that was
incredible thank you you're crazy brave
stop roasting
i don't think anybody's gonna be
bothering her while she's walking
oh boy
if you think the government's going to
be there
are you going to sit back and wait for
the cavalry
they may never come
so what are you going to do about it
why don't you start to prepare
because it's your personal
responsibility
mike the experts practical preppers have
determined that you are extremely
knowledgeable and well-rounded in your
preps your food storage is sufficient to
sustain you through a long period of
civil unrest
additionally training your german
shepherds is an excellent way to
strengthen your security and ensure that
your children will be safe in the event
you are called away from home
however if civil unrest spills over into
the suburbs your whole family may need
to evacuate and seek safety elsewhere
you need to establish a bug out location
stocked with supplies that will last you
for an extended period away from your
home
yeah we understand that we need to find
a secure alternate location and put some
stockpiles in there
also you need to put your leadership
skills to use in your community getting
your neighbors aware of and involved in
your prepping will only make your family
more secure in a crisis situation
certainly one of the things that we've
learned as we've prepped
is the fact that we can't do it alone
and we have been reaching out to
neighbors to network with them
at first we're very quiet about it we
kept it very low key but we soon
realized that there's no way we're going
to make it on our own
hey naggio just to give you a quick
update on our preps after our evaluation
we've decided to
remove some of our lawn area in our
backyard and create about a thousand
square foot garden based on a square
foot gardening concept we've got an
addition of 10 new puppies about a month
old
five of them are slated to go to people
we prep with so that was a nice little
addition to the prepping family for us
there
we'll give you updates as we move along
and thanks for the opportunity we'll
talk to you later bye
what are the odds of a global economic
collapse actually occurring
although economic turmoil in the
eurozone does not bode well
internationally the world bank has
predicted minor growth at around 2.5
percent for the year 2012.
the possibility of a global economic
collapse however cannot be completely
ruled out
next web developer preston white will go
to any length to protect his family and
friends from the nuclear radiation he
believes is raining down on the u.s
in march 2011 a devastating tsunami
crashed into the northeast coast of
japan
decimating towns and villages
in the path of this gigantic 49-foot
wall of water was the fukushima daiichi
nuclear power plant
three of its six nuclear reactors went
into meltdown leaking massive amounts of
lethal radiation into the ocean and
atmosphere the traces of which had been
found as far away as california and
alaska radiation you can't see radiation
you can't touch
people are gonna die die within months
you have to get ready
there's no other
other way but to prepare
if you're gonna survive
preston white is a mild-mannered web
developer living in central colorado but
the recent disaster at the fukushima
power plant in japan
has also made him a prepper
my life has changed being a prepper
because i'm concerned about things
you're seeing the water change into fuel
and come out as a flame some people
think i'm
obsessed with what i'm doing but look
what's happening in the world
preston believes that a cloud of deadly
radiation from fukushima is heading
towards the mainland united states and
will soon contaminate food and water
supplies oh what is that
people need to know
japan
should be
evacuated
california oregon
and washington should be evacuated
and preston is not alone in his fear for
the worst
just days after the meltdown thousands
of americans began stocking up on
potassium iodide pills to prevent
radiation poisoning
this is an extinction level event all
the bread basket of california
has been saturated with radiation
and they're finding it in the animals
they're finding it in the water
they're finding it in the food but
they're saying it's safe levels
believing that radioactive fallout from
japan will contaminate the american food
chain preston is creating a seed bank a
store of fruit and vegetable seeds that
can be used to grow radiation free food
in a post-apocalyptic world there's 400
different types of corn
750 different types of pepper seeds to
last longer than 10 years seeds must be
kept at below 40 degrees fahrenheit and
away from moisture
and today he and his friend shane are
taking a complete inventory of every
seed variety in his massive collection
let's see how much we got roma tomato uh
545 12 ounce bulk tiny tim tomatoes 700
sir yes i have 340 different types of
squash
200 different types of
peanuts i have just over 11 000 types of
seeds on this floor
a non-prepper might look at my supplies
and say are you kidding me
but if something happens i win this game
people that aren't prepared they lose
this game
preston has spent three years and tens
of thousands of dollars building up his
collection and today he's looking for
more i'm in a race
for
the seeds i would need for doomsday
right now we're going over to a
hydroponics store in town and
they have some organic seeds i was
missing
so what are you looking for today are
you growing or are you just collecting
no i'm growing now and i i want to grow
food that gives me seeds too so so if
you don't do heirloom sometimes you
can't get the seeds from the plant
correct right yeah
today preston's looking for organic
heirloom seeds known to preppers as
survival seeds i i don't have three
sisters tomatoes heirloom crops unlike
most genetically modified varieties
naturally produce a harvest of new seeds
today yeah i'll get these so what are
you doing with all these seeds fukusima
the four power plants that were over in
japan
they're sending radiation around the
earth that's gonna really
mess up things okay so
i'm trying to save seeds for food
for
maybe this town
i'd like to save the world but
it's too big see you next time okay i'll
feed the town
i'll give them some seeds
i'll give them a shovel
i think it's great to have people like
that in our community you know so if
something does happen we have seeds down
the road
hey hey make space i brought a big one
back at the house preston is working
with a team of like-minded preppers to
plant his seeds and create a
radiation-free farm
is this the horseradish yeah
so far they have managed to plant over
100 of his 11 000 varieties i'm tired of
being afraid
you know there's so much going on in the
world right now
i just feel like doing something about
it hey what's up guys i'm very worried
about fukushima because it's getting
into the food chain it's polluting the
pacific ocean all those fish
but before creating a new garden of eden
the first step on their agenda is to
protect their food supply from one of
the world's most common natural
occurrences
rain right now
about half or more of that radiation
from fukushima is still floating around
in the atmosphere and and will
eventually settle it'll eventually come
down
nuclear radiation is spread through
fallout literally radioactive particles
that fall from the sky in rain or dust
preston and his team are worried that
contaminated sea water from fukushima
will be evaporated into the atmosphere
and become deadly rain
so today preston and shane are starting
a new project that they hope will
protect their plants from the harmful
radiation
wow nice to see that
hey come on guys
[Music]
our exciting new project is the
biosphere system it's a perfect
preppers kit
if food being sold in american
supermarkets does become contaminated by
radiation these tents will act as a
barrier to potentially dangerous fallout
while still allowing enough light in to
grow food all year round
this is the living quarters
and then the other tents the the
greenhouse tank so
the biotenant will allow us to grow food
and grow seeds inside of it
that are radiation free beautiful that's
the way it's done
and then we've added a second tent
that we live in
look at this
it's
safe for your family
how long to put up
10 minutes 10 minutes
[Applause]
lettuce
and garlic
from here on out everything grows inside
these units
out of the rain
hopefully out of the air
preston and shane chose tense rather
than a more permanent structure because
they believe it will give them the
flexibility to bug out quickly if life
in town becomes too dangerous
if it's a fan we got to be ready
in case we have to leave the house and
you might have
i don't know
10 minutes
preppers believe that in order to be
sufficiently prepared not only do you
need a bug-out plan but you need to
practice that plan as regularly as once
a month today preston and shane are
seeing if they can pack up their
hundreds of thousands of seeds in under
five minutes
you ready yes sir okay
three two
go
[Music]
too slow that time
we're too slow
once they have perfected their bug out
plan preston and shane believe that the
seed bank and biosphere tents will give
them the ability to set up house
anywhere in america
that's independence that's something you
can pick up throw in the back your car
and wherever you can find a little nook
to drop it in life will go on
but if dangerous radiation seeps into
the soil and water supply systems
preston knows his biosphere tents may
not be enough
so he has a secret weapon that he hopes
will change everything this could be a
bomb right wow
[Music]
preston white is convinced that the
united states is currently facing a
nuclear apocalypse caused by the
meltdown of the fukushima daiichi power
plant in japan
he is collecting hundreds of thousands
of vegetable seeds so he can grow
radiation free food for his friends and
family how long do you think we'll have
to grow food with all the radiation
stuff lying around
the rest of our lives
protected inside a biosphere tent system
they hope they will survive widespread
radiation poisoning
look at this
this is great
but in order to survive months inside a
tent they know they need access to
energy and clean radiation free water
so they have a doomsday trump card built
by colorado local russell priester this
is my prototype of a
hho generator and
home heater the hho generator can turn
water into highly flammable gas by using
electrolysis to separate water's
hydrogen and oxygen atoms
it can literally turn water into fire
two hydrogens and one molecule of oxygen
so they call it hho turning water into
gas
hho technology has become increasingly
popular with plans to build home
generators readily available on the
internet
[Music]
you're seeing the water change into fuel
and come out as a flame this is actually
my virgin flame first time we fired this
up
wow
turning water into fire
you can use it as a cutting torch
a welding torch this is a bomb
this this could be a bomb right well
wow absolutely this is not stuff you
mess with
while impressive having the ability to
create heat from water is not the main
reason that preston and shane have
brought in an hho generator
we chose hydrogen because it's the swiss
army knife of survival it can produce
fuel to run our generators additionally
we believe
the two hydrogens and oxygen reduce
radiation at a very rapid rate
preston and shane hope that this
technology will allow them to purify not
only the water for their plants but also
the oxygen they will breathe inside the
canvas tents
any incoming water or air we're going to
process through this system before it
comes into contact with the with the
tenants in here
like most preppers security is at the
forefront of preston's mind while he is
happy to give seeds to those in need he
knows the size of his seed bank could
make him and his family a target
you have to protect what's yours
they'll take it from you
they'll take it with force
the only way you're gonna
stop them
is a weapon
if you're a prepper there's four guns to
have
you get a 30 out six a kilo a deer a
shotgun
a 22 rifle to protect your home
and a 9 millimeter pistol a side arm for
close
contact
the guns i chose i chose for defense
and recently preston's defenses were put
to the test
so i post an ad on craigslist i'm
looking for a garden partner i get a
phone call so uh this guy seems to be an
expert on
gardening yeah not much more than that
we talked for weeks okay preston
believes that he made the mistake of
giving too much away i think that they
could have been after anything in my
prepper outfit they were poly after the
seeds
soon his new contacts wanted to visit
he's on the phone
sitting out front
of the house
he's telling me that he's got a car
stuck
two miles outside town that i gotta go
help him with
i'm nervous
alarm bells are going off i reach into
my door
pull out my weapon
just for safety's sake
[Music]
preston got in the car with the mystery
gardeners just as dusk was turning into
night they proceeded to get driven just
outside of town about two miles
we pulled off into the field
and the other subject was waiting for us
i wanted to get out of the car so i
wasn't cornered
they're trying to draw me
that direction further into the darker
part of the field
it's too dark for me to go further i'm
turning around
look back i take two steps backwards and
fall down in the ravine
he shoots his weapon i pull my weapon i
fire it my first shot goes through the
tree and hits a suspect in the hand
i am now running this direction and
shooting at the same time
as i'm calling
are 911 to flee
i stopped them
although preston's alleged attackers
were subsequently apprehended as of
december 2011 no charges had been filed
due to contradictory stories and lack of
evidence to support preston's version of
events
still for preston the shooting was a
turning point
i was faced with death i decided i
wasn't gonna be
a victim
it changed my life the way i live
tomorrow
i can affect my picture and that's what
you do by prepping
we all want to change something in this
world
i hope to do something significant
the experts practical preppers are
impressed by your extensive collection
of seeds in a nuclear catastrophe this
will help you sustain life and barter
for what you need
that's what i was hoping for but your
biosphere system still needs a lot of
work and currently does not guarantee a
radiation free environment yes it's a
great concern for us but we're working
on it
shane and i didn't quite work out i wish
him well hope he does good in the future
the bio tent worked out great it's
working out great right now
and i'm hoping in the future to pick up
a motorhome and make it into a really
good bug out vehicle
what are the odds of americans being
exposed to radiation from the fukushima
reactor the radiation from the fukushima
reactors reached the united states in
march 2011. exposure levels were small
and did not cause any fatalities
colorado welder riley cook has invested
his life savings into a bug-out shelter
that he hopes will protect his family
from a catastrophic polar shift
but will he be able to get there before
the extreme weather takes hold
[Music]
riley cook is a foreman in his dad's
welding shop located in the tiny rural
town of silverthorne colorado
my family's been in the welding business
for 40 years now
in most aspects i'm a very typical
american i have a full-time job and i'm
married and have children
we go to work and we
um get our paycheck at the end of the
week and we look forward to a vacation
we got to dress up warm
but one of my primary concerns as a
father and as a husband
is will our american dream be there in
the near future for our children and for
ourselves
i'm preparing my family to survive a
polar shift
when a polar shift happens when the
north and south poles are going to shift
they could shift anywhere all the way up
to 180 degrees riley believes that
during his lifetime there will be a
catastrophic polar shift of movement of
the earth's north and south poles along
the earth's mantle and that this drastic
geological change will unleash a litany
of natural disasters you can imagine the
natural chaos that the earth would be in
there's going to be tornadoes
earthquakes
we're going to have up to 300 mile an
hour winds what will things look like
when your neighborhood is under fire
when your town has had a major
earthquake go through it your home has
been totally and completely destroyed in
a matter of seconds
[Music]
expecting chaos of truly biblical
proportions riley and his wife sarah
began to seriously prep five years ago
in the last five years we've really
taken a conscious effort to be more
prepared
with the food storage with clothing
go bags bartering items we have spent
approximately three hundred thousand
dollars in prepping
and riley's prepping has begun to creep
into other parts of his life too
his family's welding shop used to
specialize in railings and ornamental
staircases but recently they've become
known for a different kind of metal work
[Music]
we've recently become a disaster shelter
building business current government
guidelines suggest that for any disaster
from a hurricane to a nuclear war being
underground dramatically increases your
chance of survivability so riley has
started to build customized underground
bunkers that he guarantees will see you
and your family through the end of the
world i'm in a small town of about 3 500
people a big chunk of steel like this
looking like a giant pressure cooker in
the middle of their town it's been
quite the talk of our area for the last
several months
today local kirk mickelson has dropped
in to see what all the fuss is about
my curiosity got the best of me i've
driven by and seen you guys bring it in
and was curious if you could just tell
me what you were doing yeah do you have
you have uh 10 15 minutes we can go on a
quick little tour when a pull shift
occurs you will not be able to survive
in your conventional built home
that's that particular shelter is
designed for four people to be under for
90 days so what type of natural disaster
are you thinking possibly a pole shift
the north-south poles of the earth are
going to shift rotate a pole shift i've
never heard of such a thing i'm kind of
sensing that you're a little skeptical
about the whole situation well look at
the thing
i know it looks funny but when it's all
underground you won't see any of that
it's a small community so there's been a
lot of comments about it watch your head
coming in
wow you've got
hardwood floors and everything wow this
is incredible inside this is a
refrigerator in a freezer and they are
designed to run off low voltage back
here is your communication station it's
important to know with your equipment
here of what's going on outside and it's
probably not always safe to just open
the hatch and take a look you can have
ctv cameras set up out there as well on
trees or rocks or whatever
and if anyone is brave enough to try to
break into one of riley's shelters he
has devised a unique and final deterrent
one of the options that we have on our
shelters is that there's simply a button
that we have at our communication
station that will incinerate and
intruder someone that's coming in trying
to harm you you can simply push this
button right here and eliminate that
threat a torch fire chamber
just burn
burn them down yeah that's what you get
when you combine a prepper and a welder
it's a concept i've never even
considered
a pole shift but i have a family
and if something that extreme were to
happen i definitely want to keep my kids
and family safe you know
a bunker buried at a distant bug out
location is only effective if you can
get to it riley expects that the
catastrophic nature of a polar shift
will cause severe fuel shortages so he
has used his expert welding skills to
solve the problem of transportation
his latest prepping tool is a
custom-made cook original that he hopes
will allow his family to carry supplies
without needing a car or truck
someday
this just might be our new cadillac it's
the cadillac of a cooked future when a
polar shift happens we're not gonna have
the fuel supply that we're accustomed to
our vehicles are going to be worthless
therefore the hand car is a critical
element in order to get ourselves from a
to b
this 100 pound handcrafted aluminum cart
allows riley to haul almost nine times
his body weight by distributing loads in
the same way as a horse and cart except
in this scenario riley's the horse
when we first made the hand cart we
wanted to test it out and i put 1200
pounds in the hand cart
and i pulled it myself
for almost 20 miles so i know it works
the unique thing about the hand carts is
that they float like a boat they're
water tight so regularly we try and go
out and test the hand cart and make sure
that we're all comfortable in it so that
in the event that we do need it they'll
just think it's another little
family activity
this is just all part of our
preparedness kit so that we can have
transportation the way that we educate
our children and our prepping needs is
basically show them ways of preparing
for events and natural disasters that
are going to take place that have been
taking place so like with our food and
our go bags this is our cart to get us
around when there's no fuel we just want
to educate them on being prepared and
being responsible as we paddle across
the rio grande
but before riley has to resort to the
handcart he stockpiled enough fuel to
get his family to their own underground
survival shelter 11 200 feet above sea
level in the colorado mountains but will
the test run end in disaster could the
car slide off the road
riley cook and his wife sarah will do
anything to protect their family from
the onslaught of natural disasters that
they believe will follow a catastrophic
polar shift when the polar shift happens
we are not planning on wasting any time
around here we plan on getting to our
shelter as soon as possible believing
that a normal home will be no match
against earthquakes tsunamis and
superstorms they have custom-built and
underground shelter hidden 11 200 feet
up in the colorado mountains 10 miles
from the nearest form of civilization a
bugat location for us is just a place
where we can go to be safe be away from
populated areas and you could sit
through the transition period of
whatever it is the natural disasters the
social chaos the polar shift so we're
going up to the cabin we gotta dress up
warm riley believes that one of the
consequences of a polar shift will be
extreme weather patterns so he's keen to
practice bug outs to their shelter in
severe weather and today he's in luck
pretty significant storm come in last
night
it's dropped about a foot foot and a
half here at our elevation about 8 600
feet
we're going up to 11 000 feet there'll
be heavy rains there could there be
heavy snowfall if it's in the winter
those are kind of the first signs of of
a pole shift taking place this is kind
of a good practice run going up with
this much snow
okay let's go
emergency preparedness experts suggest
that you practice evacuating your home
at least twice a year and plot alternate
routes in case roads become impassable
but the remoteness of the cook shelter
means there is only one route they can
take by car this particular highway is
snow packed and icy for a good eight
months of the year
it's kind of our lifeline if you will
it's our route to our shelter so it's a
constant concern of ours i mean the hand
cart would work and could work
it would be a little more
intense
yeah a little more intense so
obviously the way we want to get there
is with by vehicle
but if all else fails we'll have to take
the handcart depending on the severity
of the weather conditions it would take
riley at least 12 hours to transport his
family to the bug-out location in his
custom-designed cart the cooks have
already been on the road for two
grueling hours and the most difficult
part of the journey is still ahead of
them driving up a completely unplowed
mountain pass
right now we're at approximately 9
600 feet in elevation anyone who's not
accustomed to this elevation they are
definitely going to start feeling some
headaches and feeling thirsty and
feeling a little bit nauseated could the
car slide off the road
not with daddy driving
at 10 000 feet they still have another 1
500 feet to travel through the heavy
snow
still climbing
[Music]
it looks treacherous here but when the
pole shift happens this is where we're
going to be the safest
we're there
despite the long and difficult journey
riley is confident that the prepping
benefits of a remote shelter outweigh
the drawbacks
all the water up here is fresh it's
mountain runoff there's a lot of
food up here as far as elk and deer if
we ever had to resort to obtaining our
food from that that's the route we would
go
[Music]
honey i'm home as you'd expect from
someone who makes survival shelters for
a living riley's bunker has it all three
years worth of food supplies 1500 pound
blast doors cctv cameras ham radio
equipment
and the odd domestic touch too
another important reason for us of
having the shelter designed the way that
it is looking like a home
is that my wife didn't want to feel like
she was living in a tank okay we got to
bring some warm clothes up why
because
so that we cannot be naked
this is a little window that we have
that reminds us of the time that we
spent together as a family outdoors
and whatever period of time we're down
here for
helps keeps us a little sane
[Music]
riley the experts have determined that
you have a highly secured underground
shelter however your shelter is too far
away and in an emergency or disaster
situation you may not make it to your
bug out location
i am going to spend more time especially
in our ways of getting to this location
and maybe moving over to the other side
of the past
there is some scientific evidence that a
true polar shift occurred 800 million
years ago but scientists believe that
because our continents are now separated
such an event is almost geologically
impossible
[Music]
you